this is a production of Cornell
University good afternoon everyone my
name is Bill Weldon and I'm a graduate
student at Cornell University in this
section of plant pathology and plant
microbiology my advisor is dr. David
godori and our lab largely focuses on
powdery mildews right now and almost all
of my graduate research is focused on
powdery mildew pops this was a
presentation that I gave in December of
2017 at the Cornell hot conference
hosted at SUNY Morrisville and I wanted
to record a copy of this presentation
and get posted online so that people
could access the PowerPoint and also
just have some audio nourish and help
hopefully explain some of the slides
because there are some animations with
some of the slides just in case as
anybody that's considering growing hops
or just currently growing hops might
find this presentation helpful so the
presentation title is differences in
managing the mildews and it's intended
to provide some help with staying out of
trouble with powdery mildew and downy
mildew which are both pathogens that we
have to worry about in hot production
quite frequently here up in the
Northeast and throughout the country
actually
[Music]
okay so why why care about downy and
powdery mildew well both pathogens are
ubiquitously distributed across New York
and the other eastern US states
throughout the Midwest and also on the
Pacific Northwest
their destruction capability is quite
high
they're capable of causing pretty
drastic yield losses they are major
factors and what pushed the New York cop
industry of the 20th century westward
and this was largely caused and any time
it's in the yard is the the losses are
caused through distortion browning and
reduction or variation in alpha acid
content so it could change the Alpha
acid profile for that given variety
which would also just make that variety
not acceptable for Brewers point of view
an example of when so powdery mildew
when it first arrived in Pacific
Northwest it caused over 10 million
dollars in losses in Washington that
first year and so it's it's really if it
it gets going in a yard it's really
quite capable of causing some pretty
significant you'll bust
so both pathogens are capable of causing
direct loss through modifying distorting
Brown and Hopkins but the downy mildew
can also have the additional impact of
causing systemic infection of the Hawk
room so the pathogen can get into the
crown of the Hotte plant and it can
exist there from season to season so
it's a systemic infection that persists
from year to year and this causes
indirect losses through the reduction in
the vigor of the hot planets so each
season the hot plant just gets less and
less vigorous until it gets the ultimate
point where one spring it would just
won't push you chopped push new new
shoots that following season and so it
can kill the hot plant that one
so the importance of properly
distinguishing between the two diseases
you might ask won't the management
approach be the same regardless of which
diseases present they're both pathogens
and I'm just gonna spray fungicides in
my yard if I see either and it doesn't
really matter whether I know which one
is actually there because I'm just gonna
be spraying anyways so what difference
does it make and that's not necessarily
the right approach and the way I think
of this is it's similar to being able to
properly respond to a fire versus a
tornado and so both are very destructive
natural disasters a fire in a tornado
but if you're sitting in your house and
you look out the window and you see a
tornado your response when you see a
tornado is to hightail it down into the
basement and that would be the right
move to make if there was in fact a
tornado outside of your house however if
you think you see a tornado you go to
the basement but in reality there's
actually a forest fire outside of your
house then by going to the basement
you've pretty much done the worst worst
thing that you could do in response to a
forest fire you you've trapped yourself
out in the basement and you're gonna end
up running around your pants on fire and
it's not gonna be a great situation and
I liken that to kind of differentiating
properly differentiating powdery and
downy mildew on between one another so
why care about the differences between
downy and powdery mildew well the two
organisms responsible for downing and
powdery belong two completely different
kingdoms so if you look at this figure
on the right here this is just a very
simple Tree of Life so you have like
your animals on one branch your plants
on another branch bacteria down here but
the branches that I want to point your
attention to are fungi you know my seeds
and the reason for that is that in fungi
so in the branch of fungi the organism
responsible for causing hot powdery
mildew is a fungus so it belongs here
and the fungus let's say is your fire
however the organism that causes hot
downy mildew is not a fungus
it's an LM I see and so this is your
tornado all right so these are two
completely different branches on the
tree of life these organisms are very
capable of causing destruction but the
reason this impacts you is that downy
mildew and powdery mildew generally
require different fungicides for good
specific control they're on different
branches and so the fungicides target
that target fungi those cellular
processes often aren't present in all my
seats because they're on a completely
different branch and so most modern
fungicides designed to control powdery
mildew do little to nothing to manage
downy mildew and vice versa
so it's critically important that you're
properly identifying what pathogen what
disease is present in your yard
because it really impacts how effective
your response is going to be so some
fungicides generally specific to downy
mildew are listed here on the left under
sides generally specific to powdery
mildew or on the right and so if you
were to think that you had powdery
mildew in your yard but you actually had
downy and then you decided to apply any
of these products on the right there
really would be very little efficacy and
kind of controlling disease because you
actually have damn email during her yard
and these these fungicides aren't
designed to target oh my seed organisms
they're
some cases of overlapping efficacy on
both powdery and downy mildew so one
example is pristine or Flint and these
products will provide downy mildew
suppression when used primarily for
powdery mildew control so there is there
are our few cases where you get a little
bit of overlapping control and maybe
your primarily sprang for powdery mildew
but you get some of this back back
handed control and Daniel do I want to
emphasize that these are examples these
products you always be used according to
the label in a given state and it's
important to check that any products
that you're using are actually labeled
for hops so some of these with a stir
seize on these slides I looked up as of
at least December of 2017 and the 2017
Cornell IPM production guide that they
are not labeled for use in New York but
they are put here as examples for people
that may be in different states so now
they're kind of the crux how to properly
differentiate between downy and powdery
mildew hopefully at this point we have a
little bit of an appreciation that these
diseases are capable of causing some
pretty drastic yield losses in your yard
and that it's important to be able to
proper properly differentiate the two
diseases between one another so now how
how to differentiate between downy
powdery mildew
what to physically look for in New York
in the case of downy mildew early in the
season the first infected shoots coming
out of ground are called basal spikes
when they are infected with Daniel do in
the case of powdery mildew these first
shoots are called flag shoots but the
basal spikes of downy mildew the very
characteristic kind of appearance of a
basal spike is a very chlorotic color so
slight yellowing in comparison to the
rest of the more kind of more vibrant
green of the healthy hot shoots there's
a general downward curling of the leaves
and the shoot appears very stunted and
so the distances between the points
where these two leaves are being
produced and this next set of leaves is
very very short and so the the shoot
appears very stunted if you look on the
underside of these leaves you're very
likely to see black purple purplish
masses of spores that are produced
exclusively on the underside of the
leaves and those are your downy mildew
spores but this is your very
characteristic basal spike which you
will see among the early shoots emerging
in the spring if downy mildew has
successfully overwintered in your yard
and is emerging on some of these new new
shoots from the case of powdery mildew
nope so here here are a couple more
examples of basal spikes in your yard or
in a yard so this is a basal spike this
is a basal spike here but then there are
other instances of some taller shoots
maybe in the background here where
they're not quite as stunted and they
the basal spikes are just very chlorotic
they're very yellow and they once it
once you've seen one on the yard they
tend to be quite noticeable you just
have to kind of be aware and cognizant
of what you're looking for these base
Spike's can also form on your lateral
branches of hops should downy mildew be
present in your yard at the time when
lateral branches are being produced and
those are called aerial spikes and they
have very character characteristics as
their basal spikes except they're
forming on your lateral branches and so
there they could be higher up in the
canopy but they're again those new buds
that are pushing and you get these very
chlorotic leaves with down lower stunted
growth they curl downwards and you're
you'll likely see masses of damning
mildew on the underside of the leaves so
in the case of powdery mildew they're
termed flag chutes and these flag shoots
again emerge early spring when the hops
start breaking ground and the buds that
emerge infected with powdery mildew up
here as this picture to the right where
the shoot is very strikingly white the
leaves are also typically stunted but
the major kind of defining
characteristic of a flag shoot is just
the striking white appearance in
comparison to all of the green healthy
tissue that doesn't have powdery mildew
surrounding it and that's that's where
the term flag shoot comes from it sticks
out like flag one other difference
between downy and powdery mildew is the
coloration of the spores so downy mildew
has very darkly pigmented spores and
this results in clusters of purple to
black colonies on the leaf these
colonies exist exclusively on the
underside of the weave which is very
it's a very defining characteristic of
downy mildew so if you're questioning
whether you have downy mildew in your
yard or not and you see spores being
produced on the upper side of the leaf
that's kind of a deterrent and maybe
makes you think that maybe it's not
downy mildew you should be only saying
spores on the underside of the leaves in
the case of downy alternatively for
powdery mildew they produce transparent
non-pigmented spores and this results in
masses of clear spores that when you're
looking at it macroscopically appears
white fluffy colonies on the leaf
and these colonies can be produced both
on the upper surface and the lower
surface of your leaves the hop cones
also the case for Daddy mill do on your
stems pretty much any green above ground
tissue
um can harbor these these organisms so
these are some of your downy mildew
sports you can see that they're darkly
pigmented and when you start looking at
these with your naked eye so okay in
comparison this is these are your spores
produced by powdery mildew and they are
not pigmented they kind of appear in
these little stacks of bead-like spores
and when you look at that microscope
macroscopically with with your eye what
you see is kind of a white fluffy cotton
and so here are the examples of what you
might see when you just look at it
visually again notice how downy mildew
is these all these spores are on the
underside of the leaf they are black to
purple and so they are much darker
typically than your powdery mildew
colonies and when you look at the
powdery mildew leaf it's very strikingly
white it's a little bit fluffier it kind
of looks like snow if if it's on circus
the weaves some of the older colonies
can look a little bit matte grey if
they're if they're old and not producing
any new spores but typically the thing
that gives away powdery mildew is the
white fluffy colonies on here Crede
green tissue so we're on the plant is
the disease found for downy mildew and I
said this before the spores are produced
exclusively on the underside of the
leaves and that is a big big
differentiation between downy and
powdery mildew the lesions will be
angular which means that if you look at
a leaf and you can see the leaf things
kind of extending out across the leaf
the lesions will be trapped in between
those veins they can't extend past those
veins and so those veins kind of trap
the little lesions into angular kind of
shapes and for downy mildew the growth
can spread into the hop crumb and cause
that systemic infection for powdery
mildew the
spores can be found on all green plant
tissue and this includes both sides the
leaves and so if you're seeing something
that's forming on the top side of the
leaf and you're trying to differentiate
between downy and powdery that's a good
indication that you might be dealing
with powdery mildew and again it cannot
cause systemic infection of the crumbs
and that is only only something worried
about however in both cases the dormant
buds that exist sort of just beneath the
soil line during the winter can be
colonized by both downy and powdery
mildew and that's how your basal spikes
in the case of downy mildew and your
flag shoots in case of powdery mildew
emergence room so this is a picture
example of the angular motions that I
was talking about for downy mildew and
so you see your leaf veins and then
there's even smaller leaf veins that are
progressing through the spaces between
the larger ones and those are trapping
your downy mildew colonies into very
angular shapes here's what it looks like
from the top and again so the spores are
only only underside the leaf on the top
will start to show slight discoloration
that might turn necrotic brown color as
the leaf gets older but they are in in
line with where the colonies are forming
on the underside of the leaf and so
that's that's a response to the colonies
forming on the underside of the leaf
here's another case this is a slightly
older downy mildew colony again you can
see those angry angular lesions but they
are turning more more of a brown color
because the colonies are much older it
caused more damage to the leaf as time
has passed in case of powdery mildew you
this is just an example of the very
white fluffy spores that Shema in the
colonies that you might see if you're
coming across powdery mildew new yard
and they are caused by the clear spores
that build up and the amounts of
hundreds of thousands and appear white
when you're just looking at it with your
eye they are capable of spreading to any
green above-ground plant tissue so here
it is on a hot comb
and in the case of downy mildew it can
also cause the brown discoloration it's
it's a little bit of a darker kind of
reddish brown in the case of downy
mildew in the case of powdery mildew
it's more of your traditional kind of
just necrosis and you'll probably be
able to see some of the white powdery
growth on the cone but the easiest way
to identify these pathogens is not by
differentiating how your cone looks you
should have
leaf kind of damage harboring either
downy mildew or powdery mildew around
and that's that's much easier to
differentiate than trying to decide on
which pathogen is causing a problem
based on how the cones are working so
one note about varietal resistance for
hot downy mildew is that there are two
ways as I said that hop down T mildew
can cause damage to a plant it can
affect your hop cones and cause a direct
you loss through damaged vodka and then
it can cause the systemic infection that
causes a year-to-year reduction in the
yield potential of that plant as it gets
weaker from year to year from having
been systemically infected and that
creates kind of this spectrum of
resistance across plants where some
plants may be resistant to the foliar
aspect of downy mildew but susceptible
to the systemic infection or susceptible
to both foliar and systemic resistant to
both or whichever the last one the
resistant to the foliar are susceptible
to the Foley or resistant to a systemic
infection and so it breaks out into
these four quadrants and really kind of
results in more of a spectrum than a
clear-cut definition of this variety for
Danny mildew is resistant because there
is there are so many factors at play
that it unless it's completely resistant
to both full ear infection and your
crown systemic infection then there's
going to be kind of spectrum above the
resistance associated with that variety
when considering the vara varietal
resistance to powdery mildew again there
are some variety
that are published as resistant to
powdery mildew in the US and then there
are some that have recently lost
resistance in Pacific Northwest and so
the varieties nugget and Cascade have
strains of powdery mildew that have been
found out there where the strains are
kind of adapted to grow better than they
normally would be able to so that
resistance has recently lost in stiff
northwest and these are varieties that
are worth paying attention to on the
East Coast because it's worth knowing
and tracking whether these strains
president Pacific Northwest I've made
their way eastward
so another way to properly
the disease is to know the optimal
conditions for downy and powdery mildew
there are basically kinds of weather
that favor one disease over the or the
other and so typically you get general
seasons that favor high prevalence of
either downy mildew or powdery mildew
four downy mildew these are your rainy
seasons so it's strongly favored by wet
rainy conditions seasons of high
humidity and long due periods are also
conducive for downy mildew and spores
are pigmented there on the inner side of
the leaf which these are conditions
conducive for high humidity if this is
relevant to you this would the 2017
growing season was a very conducive
season where we got a lot of rain there
were long periods of leaf wetness and
the downy mildew spore actually requires
wet leaf wetness
it requires moisture on the surface of
the leaf in order to be able to infect
the host and so that was a very very
favorable growth season for downy mildew
in the case of powdery mildew it's
favored during seasons of temperate or
more dry conditions it doesn't require
water to infect the plant so
theoretically every day is a potential
infection period but the conditions that
are most favorable for powdery mildew
are kind of your temperate overcast days
where there's not direct sunlight
because those spores are not pigmented
the Sun can damage the spores and then
kill them off the 2016 growing season in
New York was or was an example of a
season that was favored favorable for
powdery mildew it was much drier than
2017 and we saw many more cases of
powdery mildew that year so now now that
you've properly identified what disease
is in your yard it's important to know
how to properly manage of downy and
powdery mildew so kind of the first and
foremost way to make your life easier is
to choose resistant varieties when
possible this has to be taken in
consideration with varieties that are in
May
on the brewing industry obviously but
when possible at least always give
consideration to the resistance or the
susceptibility of the varieties that
you're planting in your yards that you
go in with realistic expectations of how
intensive your disease management
program is going to be if this is
especially important for organic
production and it will also guide your
scouting intensity regardless of whether
you're growing organically or
conventionally as well as your spray
program intensity because it will inform
you kind of how how at-risk are you for
for infection of both downy or powdery
mildew so you should you should be
scouting as soon as shoots emerge and
scout as often as fees as feasible for
your operation I know this can be tough
and some critical scouting periods for
downy mildew are at shoot emergence at
the start of the season because those
are when you're gonna identify your
basal spikes and you would want to rogue
those out at the time of shoot training
this is another time that's very
important because if you're growing tips
of your shoots are infected with downy
mildew they will become stunted they
will stop growing upwards and they will
likely fall from the trellis which will
require you to have to retrain shoots
which could result in a yield loss just
basically by improper it messes with
your training time at the time of
production of lateral branches so those
aerial spikes that we mentioned those
can become a problem during the time
production of lateral branches and say
you once got well trying to start
because this can basically cause your
lateral branches to be killed off which
would result in a yield loss because
those would be branches that would not
result in forming proper Hopkins and
then you should also be scouting one
week prior to bloom through four weeks
post bloom because this is the period
when the hop cones are atmo are most at
risk for become
infected with downy mildew so the cones
are most susceptible during this time
and if they become infected during this
time they're gonna result in the
greatest amount of distortion the
greatest fluctuation away from the norm
of the alpha acid level your beta is
away from whatever that variety should
be behaving as will be most affected
them if they get infected during this
time for powdery again scout as soon as
shoots emerge and scout as often as
possible the two major critical scouting
periods for powdery mildew are at shoot
emergence at the start of the season so
you should be scouting forget the flag
shoots and be rolling those out should
you find any and then one week prior to
bloom through the three weeks post bloom
because this is the period when the hop
cones are most susceptible to powdery
mildew infection and the cones are most
affected and most result in kind of the
greatest amount of distortion and
improper alpha and beta acid levels in
cones so it's easy to tell you just a
scout and that's a very big thing to say
so hopefully those times are helpful and
then also here's a general scouting
approach so when disease pressure is low
you should be scouting one to two
hundred plants every time you Scout and
they should be evenly dispersed among
varieties and throughout your yard
should pay special attention to the
basal foliage as well as any young still
developing hop cones and leaves your
basal foliage that's a very conducive
microclimate for the development of
downy and powdery mildew so it's
protected from sunlight often on the
humidity levels a little bit higher so
that would favor your downy mildew and
this is also just a part of the yard a
level of the yard we're very young kind
of actively growing hop tissue is being
produced and the youngest hop tissue is
typically the most susceptible part of
the hop plant for downy and powdery
mildew or infection for downy look for
the basal spikes and dark spores on the
underside of the leaves for powdery look
for your white powdery colonies and
especially on your young
any kind of suspect shoots or leaves
that you might see in your yard you can
kind of do an at-home Hema chamber to
try and cause these organisms to produce
spores which are very characteristic
giveaways for what disease you might be
dealing with so remove a question we'll
shoot and place it inside of a ziploc
bag with a damp paper towel for downy
you want to store this bag at room
temperature in the dark because they
spoil you late or in the dark and that
will be the easiest way to confirm
whether or not it's downy mildew for
powdery stored at room temperature in a
spot that gets daily light-dark cycles
because that is associated with how
powdery mildew produces its pores and
the end goal is just to try and get the
chute in question to produce spores
because that's the easiest way to figure
out what what organism what disease you
may be dealing with so check for
production of spores after one or two
days obviously
fungicides are very crucial and control
of both of these diseases and it's
important to know your fungicides so
it's crucial to know which fungicides
apply to downy mildew or to powdery
mildew you can check the label if you're
unsure sometimes it won't specifically
say downy mildew or or specifically
powdery mildew but in those cases and
often will say other organisms that if
you do a quick Google search you could
figure out whether that's a fungus or a
gnome I see if we think back to that
tree of life the fire versus the tornado
and if there's a bunch of my seats
listed on that label it's likely
applying to oh my seats which is it as a
downy mildew organism but just check the
label if you're unsure and be sure that
you're using the right fungicide to
target the organism that you think is in
your yard there are many applications
decisions to make the on label I'm
seeming to think about the efficacy of
the fungicide the potential for
resistance so maybe saving your big guns
for just the most crucial times during
the growing season the longevity
retention redistribution of these zones
so those decisions just beyond deciding
what fungicide product do you want to
use like I just said saved a big guns
for most critical management periods in
the case of powdery mildew this would be
around bloom that was one two three week
period that we were talking about so
your quintic your pristine again make
sure that these are products that are
labeled
for use in your state dining mildew how
this could be remiss plus phosphorus
acids and pro these are typically kind
of big guns for control of these
pathogen so you want to save them very
much critical critical times where you
need great control there are some shared
cultural practices for both downy and
mildew you downy mildew and powdery
mildew that are kind of the legwork
quote-unquote to make your fungicides
work better so if you do this stuff it's
easier to keep these diseases under
control and your fungicides or have
greater efficacy if kind of these
cultural practices are part of
management approach some pruning and/or
crowning are is a strategy that you do
if they started the growing season to
remove some of those buds that may have
overwintered with powdery or downy
mildew on them and so this would cut
back your first flush of growth
essentially that may have shoots that
would eventually become your basal
spikes in the case of downy or flag
shoots in case of powdery and we would
kill those those off and so then
hopefully that second flush of growth
that comes from deeper in the soil does
not have any powder your downy mildew on
it and you're left with only healthy hop
tissue the training time is important
because it gets the shoots that you want
cut off the ground and away from all the
basal foliage and then this allows you
to focus on cleaning up that basal
foliage which can Harbor and be kind of
a microclimate ideal for development
both of these diseases stripping the
lower leaves is an option and so guys
have some photos associated with this
and so pruning these might be your first
flush of growth cut these back you might
be able to remove either the basal
spikes or the five shoots that emerge in
this flush of growth training times
picture associated with that and then
here's a picture to help describe what
we mean by stripping the lower leaves
you're breaking the green bridge so all
that basal foliage the hot tissue
growing along the soil line that might
connect each plant kind of bridge that
distance between the plants so this
distance right here we're splitting that
up and we're also increasing airflow
through the yard stripping the lower
leaves is not recommended for young
yards so your first your second your
yards and also some varieties don't
respond well to losing their first three
feet of wee foliage so you're left less
vigorous varieties might might this
might not be something that you'd want
to do for them
and here here's an instance of what I
mean by the green bridge and so you can
see this hot tissue going along the soil
line and effectively connecting these
two plants to one another and so it
could feasibly happen where powdery
mildew just kind of crawls along spreads
from leaf to leaf and all of a sudden
you have it in this plant and so
anything you can do to break that cream
bridge is good some good sources of
information to reference the Cornell
integrated hops production guide is put
out each year and this is New York
specific information regarding labeled
chemistry's so each year that list gets
updated and changes slightly it's
available through the Cornell bookstore
and this is not relevant
I guess the relevance now as this is
posted is that the 2018 Edition is
available there's also the field guide
for integrated pest management hops the
link can be found on the USA hops
website with the research and technical
tab I think if you do a google search of
this title you can find it on a handful
of different websites a link to it but
that's one that has worked for me past
the 2017 Michigan hop management guide
they did a very very nice job there at
Michigan State University Extension
that's very good
management guide another one for the
East Coast and then one of my projects
that I've been working on I put together
a hops web page for Cornell and so we
have that here so if you google search
Cornell sips hops or follow this URL
here you'll be taken to the hops page
for Cornell and here we've up up loaded
some outreach content some disease
management stuff so management of hot
downy mildew managing the mildew so kind
of a pared down version of this talk
five considerations for ever planning
your first hop management of powdery
mildew and this is something that we
hope to continually update as more
articles are put together that is
where this talk will be uploaded to and
is hopefully just going to become kind
of a reliable source of hop related
content so with that thank you for your
time feel free to email me if you have
any questions my email is on the first
slide
it's ww3 9/5 at cornell edu and with
that yeah thank you here's my email
again and I hope you have a good day
thank you this has been a production of
Cornell University on the web at cornell
edu